carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
un gusto saludarles desde parís les
enviamos nuestros deseos por que este
año sea próspero y luminoso y en el menú
de nuestro programa de hoy las figuras
clave del 2022 cultural en francia y
algunos de los encuentros que nos
marcaron en el año que acaba de terminar
iremos al museo de la legión de honor
una condecoración y tradición francesa
que remonta a la época de napoleón y que
aún se sigue entregando en francia'
conoceremos la obra del muralista jvc
quien retrata a iconos de la cultura
popular y se inspira en los colores y
motivos de américa latina' e iremos al
encuentro de carmen maría vega artista
francesa nacida en guatemala y víctima
de tráfico de niños
una historia que ella cuenta en sus
canciones
[Música]
comenzamos a este carrusel hablándoles
de algunas de las conmemoraciones
nacionales en 2022 en francia el año
comienza recordando al padre de la
comedia francesa molière el autor de
piezas de teatro mundialmente conocidas
como tartufo o el enfermo imaginario
será homenajeado en todo el país en el
400 aniversario de su nacimiento lo será
también marcel justa en el marco del
centenario de su muerte con un sinnúmero
de publicaciones sobre su obra y
reediciones de en busca del tiempo
perdido uno de los libros más
importantes de la literatura francesa y
universal 'francia conmemorará asimismo
a su médico más célebre y reconocido
louis pasteur en los 100 años de su
muerte y ayón fonso a john paul jones
considerado el padre de la egiptología
quien fue el primero en descifrar la
escritura jeroglífica
y cada 1º de enero hace su aparición en
la legión de honor la condecoración más
prestigiosa que se entrega en francia en
2022 547 personalidades fueron
distinguidas con esta medida con esta
medalla creada por napoleón les
invitamos a conocer el museo de la
legión de honor en parís es un reportaje
de melissa barra
[Música]
el museo de la legión de honor en el
corazón de parís abarca 200 años de
historia a través de la distinción más
importante en francia creada en 1802
[Música]
y buena parte se dio cuenta de que los
ciudadanos no necesitaban ser alentados
y que la nación necesitaba una élite
visible que sirviera de modelo en europa
otros sistemas distinguían a los
funcionarios con rangos de nobleza y con
decoraban a los soldados pero la
modernidad de la legión de honor yace en
su universalidad no se hace distinción
entre los méritos y miles y la valentía
militar porque todos están al servicio
de una misma nación tus ofertas son por
servicio de la nación que tiene
[Música]
cuando se creó la insignia se escogió
una estrella con puntas vividas como la
cruz de malta pero se le agregó a una
quinta punta para volverla laica en una
cara tiene la figura del emperador y en
el reverso un águila imperial el símbolo
heráldico que napoleón escogió para su
imperio bajo la restauración borbónica
se puso al rey enrique cuarto y una flor
de lis y desde que se instauró la
república vemos un perfil de la diosa
ceres efigie de la república y detrás
las banderas entrecruzadas la estrella
está rodeada de una corona de hojas de
roble y de laurel que representan los
méritos civil y militar el emérito se
viene militar
de la legión de honor se abarca un gran
abanico de profesiones y sectores del
país el criterio es haber servido a la
nación durante 20 años o destacarse por
un acto espectacular fue recompensado
por ejemplo louis pasteur a finales del
siglo 19
últimamente fueron distinguidos
profesionales del sector salud que
luchan en primera línea contra la
pandemia de lakovic hay astronautas
también como toma pesqué quien fue
nombrado caballero tras su primera
expedición y extranjeros como el autor
gabriel garcía márquez o rigoberta
menchú quien recibió la legión de honor
por su defensa de los derechos humanos
de duatlón
hoy en día viven en francia y en el
mundo más de 90.000 legionarios
[Música]
a continuación vamos a conocer a un
artista urbano que vive y trabaja en la
capital francesa pero que tiene un
vínculo muy fuerte con américa latina'
una influencia que es perceptible en su
obra lo conocimos frente a una pintura
dedicada a la fallecida cineasta
francesa agnès varda
me llamo yo matiz cola conocido como gps
otra vez en español soy artista urbano
muralista para ser más exactos aquí mi
especialidad es la pintura el fresco
sobre las paredes lo que llamamos los
murales
siempre me ha interesado el concepto del
icono por ejemplo he visto que en
américa latina' del arte popular está
muy impregnado de religión y la figura
icónica digamos que es recurrente
entonces poco a poco me ha ido pidiendo
retratos porque iba hacía iconos de
personas personajes populares deportivos
de la cultura de la música del arte y
entonces ha venido esa especialización
de el retrato de forma un poco natural
de
américa latina está muy presente en mi
obra y esto es una historia bastante
antigua que tenía un padre que era
profesor de francés y nos llevó toda la
familia a vivir en distintos países de
américa latina ha habido uruguay ha
habido también españa hablando de un
país hispanohablante y luego pues
corazones personales también estuve muy
vinculado con colombia con ecuador
también todo esto ha creado un gusto por
esos colores tropicales que para mí son
muy vinculados a latinoamérica
fuera de esto también la forma de vestir
los colores de los trajes tradicionales
todo esto es una estética los patrones
también de esos vestidos han creado
también han sido una fuente de
inspiración muy fuerte para mí
este mural que está detrás de mí es es
un homenaje a una gran cineasta que es
arriesgada que murió hace dos años esa
señora vivió muchos años aquí en este
barrio en la ruta guías para ser más
preciso y lo que quiso hacer la alcaldía
del 14 hacerle un homenaje un homenaje
picture al he tenido el gran honor de
ser el artista que cogieron para poder
pintar este homenaje lo que está
representado acá es una selección de
varias escenas de esas películas
parecidas daños gana el arte urbano
también en ese periodo de crisis que
hemos tenido ha dado un sentido especial
a lo esencial que tiene que ser la
cultura precisamente cuando los lugares
estaban cerrados
nosotros los muralistas hemos podido
seguir dando acceso a la cultura a la
gente y precisamente es poder compartir
esto lo que me encanta
[Música]
damos paso a nuestra crónica musical con
una tablet olivares quien fue el
encuentro de una artista francesa pero
nacida en guatemala su nombre es carmen
maría vega y ella nos confió su historia
como víctima del tráfico de niños algo
que ya ha contado en sus canciones y en
un libro
[Música]
la voz de carmen maría griega la
encontramos aquí en el distrito 10 de la
capital unas voces de fuego que tiene
mucho mucho mucho que contar y se la
presentamos
[Música]
en esta canción niño de fuego
primero la experiencia de una ceremonia
religiosa maya que hice con rigoberta
menchú en su casa y sus dos guías
espirituales en ese momento le
preguntaron al fuego cuál era mi
elemento y al parecer mi elemento es el
fuego la
niña de fuego es un guiño de ojo a eso y
se refiere también a un temperamento
latino y francés que me caracteriza
hermoso así bueno
[Música]
la canción la niña de fuego la fi de fe
es una canción clave en el disco de
carmen maría vega llamado santamaría
escrito tras la búsqueda de su madre
biológica en guatemala una historia
increíble de tráficos de niños con
europa esto resulta ser un terremoto y
en sus canciones llega revela su gran
secreto una verdad sorprendente y un
vuelco en su vida
curvas con un gran día el gran secreto
es como un castillo de naipes que se
derrumba yo creía que mi madre era una
activista que nos abandonó con
conciencia y por una causa así que de
alguna manera creí que me había salvado
la vida hay algo mágico entre comillas
al creer que mi madre era una mujer
feminista combativa la canción el gran
secreto es que descubrimos que en
américa latina y una trata de niños de
la cual yo fui última tras la guerra y
que duró muchísimo tiempo en guatemala
empezó durante los años 60 y pues para
mí descubrir todo esto a los 25 o 26
años fue un terremoto yo tenía la
necesidad de sal de entender pues ahora
entiendo no me esperaba encontrarme con
esa verdad y en mis padres tampoco
creían que todo era legal y que si había
demoras en algunos expedientes pues era
normal y cristianos tratando este tema
normal
[Música]
canción se llama el gran secreto y a
pesar de haber descubierto sus raíces su
madre biológica y con ella su idioma
materno
carmen marilla vega no ha podido superar
la barrera del castellano
[Música]
una especie de rechazo del espanyol no
lo puedo explicar pero es como si
tuviera una pequeña caja en mi cerebro
que dijera que no y todavía hoy para mí
es absolutamente complicado hablar en
español no es nada fácil y no hay
rechazo a mi cultura pero ahí la rechazo
a la ley
[Música]
carmen maría vega y la historia de su
vida artística e íntima revela un
problema internacional el de los bebés
robados y vendidos
si escuchas y también se lee en su libro
autobiográfico el canto de la cabra de
sonia
[Música]
el canto de la cabra es dónde busca hace
referencia a dos cosas a la tragedia
griega pero también es un personaje
recurrente que está en mi libro es el
nombre de la persona que dirigía la
asociación de nuestras adopciones
ilegales
muchas gracias carmen maría por la ayuda
de vista
gracias
[Música]
dónde
sí
luna
[Música]
gracias natal olivares y con el tema
agridulce de carmen maría vega les vamos
a despedir de este carrusel de las artes
agradeciéndoles por su amable sintonía
agua
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i bien
[Música]
no no
y
sí